M M's has just made a major announcement
as retired it's spokes candies
and hired
a new spokeslady
Eminem's tweets at America let's talk
and last year we've made some changes to
our beloved spokes candies we weren't
sure if anyone would even notice and we
definitely didn't think it would break
the internet but now we get it
even a Candy's shoes can be polarizing
which was the last thing Eminem's wanted
since we're all about bringing people
together
therefore we've decided to take an
indefinite pause from the spokes candies
in their place we are proud to introduce
a spokesperson America can agree on the
Beloved Maya Rudolph we're confident Ms
Rudolph Will Champion the power of fun
to create a world where everyone feels
they belong
I like Maya Rudolph
very funny lady I think she was friends
with Norm Macdonald that's really all
you need for me to have respect for you
I want to be perfectly clear
M M's marketing problems will not go
away
until they bring back the sexy green
Eminem
until that green m m is sexy again
it's not going to go away I'm not saying
this to be provocative I'm not saying
this as a threat I am simply observing
that fact
you may recall last year M Ms decided to
take all the fun little differentiating
factors about all the little M M's
characters and do what our culture is
doing to everybody and try to make them
all kind of uniform and androgynous
and so they turned the green Eminem Who
had previously been a sexy little
trollop of an m m and turned her into a
kind of tomboyish
androgynous gender neutral candy
and there was a lot of backlash to this
and the libs made fun of us I think
Tucker had a real field day with the
whole green m m sexy thing but the lips
made fun of us they said were you
weirdos why do you care about a sexy m m
because it's a symbol no I don't think
that there are very many people out
there who are lusting over the m m but
it is perfectly rational to be concerned
that M M's is making the m m less sexy
because the m m is a symbol it's a
symbol of the way that we are viewing
women in our culture and that's what
people have problems with we have
problems that we're chopping off the
breasts of teenage girls and we're
forcing men forcing women rather to
change with men in their locker rooms
and we're now posting Billboards not of
beautiful models to be surrounded by
images of beauty even if they're
somewhat idealized through Photoshop and
lighting and special effects but now
we're intentionally posting grotesque
pictures and grotesqueries all over
our culture not even just in terms of
models but in terms of all Aesthetics
that's what people are concerned about
we're concerned that we now have a
culture that is forcing us to live
according to lies and forcing us to call
good evil and Truth falsehood and Beauty
ugliness that's what we're concerned
about and Eminem's is doing nothing to
solve that problem they're saying whoa
whoa whoa we didn't expect a backlash
because we we took the stilettos off the
candy whoa okay well to correct that
we're just going to get rid of it
entirely no we don't want that either
that's it's such an annoying
fact about our culture it's such an
annoying response these days which is
you have a traditional thing
and then you have the liberal agitation
to get rid of the traditional thing and
then the culture caves to the liberal
agitation
then you have backlash from the
conservatives and then they just get rid
of the thing altogether I remember this
I was in college I was on freshman
student government in college
and in college we were going to have a
freshman dance and so we decided it was
going to be Gone With the Wind theme
because our class president that year
was a southern guy and it'd be nice you
wear fun costumes or whatever and then
as always it's like liberal white kids
saying this is very offensive to black
people not to me and no black people are
complaining but it's offensive I'm
offended on behalf of the black people
and
so what happened was the the school
didn't the student government we didn't
stick to our guns
we didn't come up with some new
interesting idea we just got rid of the
theme I think the theme ended up being
the color blue or something and that's
what our culture does it always just
goes down to the absolute lowest common
denominator so that we get rid of all
these fun little ornate things that
define our very culture we say okay
we're gonna get rid of that we'll just
have a regular spokesman like all the
other companies okay that's fine no it's
not fine come on guys
I want things that are ornate I want
things that are specific and eccentric
and traditional I want
the sexy green Eminem
that's what I want okay the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles Canada
wlas at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans
we'll see you in the member block
[Music]